Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin auf dieser Station.
Stopp, stopp. Sie waren sehr schnell. Ich habe Sie leider nicht verstanden.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich gerne. Aber wie ist Ihr Name noch einmal? Können Sie es langsam aussprechen?
Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden.
Ipec.
Ah, jetzt. Dankeschön. Ipec.
Ist das ein türkischer Name?
Ja, türkische Nachname.
Ah, okay.
Bevor wir über Ihre Empfehlung sprechen, muss ich Sie um persönliche Daten bitten.
Zum Beispiel, wie heißen Sie?
Der Name ist Andreas.
Thöller. Andreas ist mein Vorname.
Können Sie das vorwärts nachnehmen?
Andreas Anton Nordholm.
Dora Richard Emil. Anton Siegfrieds. Andreas.
Und der Nachname ist Thöller.
Zeppelin.
Öl. Doppel L. Emil Richard. Thöller.
Okay, Herr Thöller. Ja, richtig?
Jawohl.
Herr Thöller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. März, 1980.
92, wahrscheinlich.
92, 92, ja.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 82.
Wie sind Sie Ihre aktuelle Gewicht?
Ja, ungefähr 85 kg.
95.
Nun, Herr Thöller, welche besten Fälle haben Sie? Wie kann ich Ihnen halten?
Also, Herr Thöller, ich bin nicht gekommen, weil ich gehört habe, dass Sie ein sehr guter Arzt sind.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe seit zwei Wochen Durchfälle, aber jetzt ein paar Tage ist auch etwas Blut dabei.
Das hat mich ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht.
Einfach Blut.
Wie oft müssen Sie abführen?
Also, anfänglich waren es nur ein bis zwei Mal, weil jetzt habe ich so vier, fünf Mal am Tag.
Weiche Stuhlgang.
Wie sagt der Stuhlgang aus am Anfang?
Dann haben Sie Blut schon geblieben, aber dann haben Sie noch nicht geblieben.
Das ist ein bisschen Blut.
Wie sagt der Stuhlgang aus am Anfang?
Danach haben Sie Blut schon geblieben, aber am Anfang, gertlich zum Beispiel, war es ganz normal.
Ja, war es weich, aber die Farbe war normal.
Farbe war normal.
Ja.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass das auslöser sei?
Ich kann nicht sagen, aber ich muss sagen, ich habe seit einem halben Jahr,
die war wieder so kramfartige Bauchschmerzen.
Mal mehr, mal weniger.
Jetzt in letzter Zeit ist es verstärkt.
Seit wann versteckt sich die Schmerzen?
Seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Wochen, versteckt.
Könnten Sie die Bauchschmerzen genau becherben?
Entschuldigung, Sie haben kramfartige gesagt.
Okay, wichtig sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 ist sehr lecker, 10 ist sehr stark, die Schmerzen spielten.
Ich würde mal sagen, am Anfang waren Sie so vielleicht bei 2 bis 3.
Und jetzt ist es so stärker, 5 bis 6.
Okay.
Aber das ist nicht immer, aber immer öfter.
Öfter.
Und jetzt pröken Sie.
Habt ihr etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Ja, also wenn ich etwas esse, dann merke ich, dass es schlimmer wird.
Deswegen habe ich auch meinen Essen deutlich reduziert.
Ich habe auch wenig Appetit.
Es ist eigentlich egal.
Ich dachte, es ist zuerst auf Milchprodukte, wie jenes wie Joghurt.
Aber eigentlich ist es egal, was ich esse, dass Schmerzen kommen, immer.
Ja, ich verstehe, es ist sehr schwer, aber wir haben diese erfahrene und kompetente Obererste.
Wie können Sie genau behandeln?
Das machen Sie ganz wahr.
Deswegen bin ich hierher gekommen.
Dankeschön.
Das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Also oft ist es im Oberbauch.
Aber das wechselt immer.
Dann habe ich es auch mal im rechten Unterbauch, dann ist es auch mal im linken Unterbauch.
Aber in letzter Zeit verstärkt er im linken Unterbauch.
Ich stelle die Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus.
Wenn die Schmerzen kommen, dann strahlt es in den ganzen Bauch raus.
Das kann ich sagen, dass es in eine bestimmte Richtung geht.
Das ist manchmal überall.
Haben Sie vielfach bemerkt?
Lieber habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Super, ich stelle die Schmerzen nach Schweiß.
Was von Schweiß?
Schmerzen, Schmerzen, Stülfrost.
Nein, das habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Im letzten halben Jahr habe ich sieben nach Kilo abgenommen.
Vielleicht habe ich auch etwas weniger gegessen.
Ich habe weniger Appetit, und dementsprechend weniger gegessen.
Aber die Gewichtsabnahme ist unwirklich?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe weniger gegessen, weil ich weniger Appetit habe.
Und nach jedem Essen immer wieder die Schmerzen.
Leiten Sie unter Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Leichte Übelkeit, aber Erbrechen habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Okay, und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, Wasserlassen klappt eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay, und dann haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nein, das müssen wir nicht.
Waren Sie für diese Beschwerden beim Arzt?
Ich war nur beim Hausarzt.
Der hat gemeint, wir sollen erst mal abwarten, aber ansonsten war ich nicht mal bei ihm.
Ich bin jetzt direkt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay, ich verstehe Ihnen.
Leiden Sie unter Brustchmerzen, Ängige oder Herzrasen?
Nein, mit dem Herz oder Brust habe ich keine Probleme.
Ich dachte, die Bauchschmerzen reichen mir schon.
Also Probleme will ich auch nicht noch haben.
Leiden Sie unter Zutrennen?
Manchmal, ja.
Okay, Gehinwinde ab.
Was haben Sie gemeint?
Gehinwinde ab.
Luft geht raus, das ist kein Problem.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie Sauergeschmack oder Saueresaufstossen bemerkt?
Wie gesagt, nur manchmal, aber nicht so oft.
Manchmal.
Okay, und leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, Herr Zöller?
Nein, bisher habe ich noch nichts dazu.
Ich bin eigentlich sehr sportlich, ich lebe gesund.
Ich habe bisher eigentlich nie Probleme gehabt.
Deswegen wundere ich mich jetzt sehr.
Okay, ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Medikamente einnehmen.
Nein, ich habe nur manchmal Karazithamol genommen,
weil ich sehr stark das Schmerzen hatte, aber
ich habe noch keinen Schmerzen, aber ich habe noch keinen Schmerzen.
Ja, dann haben wir einen Schmerzen.
500 mg Maschine?
Ja, ja.
Okay, super.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein.
Keine Operation.
Ist Ihnen allergie bekannt?
Ich habe nicht gehört, aber nur Polnallergie.
Wie heißt es die Allergie?
Da muss ich oft ließen, meine Augen trennen, meine Nase läuft.
Aber das ist meistens dann, ja, ein, zwei Wochen wieder vorbei.
Hm, okay, super.
Was sind Sie von Beruf her?
Ich bin Projektmanager.
Hm, meine Güte.
Sind Sie zufrieden bei uns?
Bei der Art-Sentronie?
Sind Sie zufrieden?
Womit bin ich zufrieden, z.B.?
Mit der Arbeit.
Ach so, mit der Arbeit, ja, ja.
Ich liebe meine Arbeit, ja.
Hm, okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Super.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, noch nicht.
Keine Kinder.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrer Frau wahr sein?
Ja, ja, natürlich, ja. Wir wohnen zusammen.
Super.
Okay, und, Herr Söller, wie ist Ihre Eltern?
Sind Sie noch gesund?
Meine Eltern?
Ja.
Also, wie weißt du, ich weiß.
Haben Sie bisher keine ernsthaften Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Ah, super. Wie alt ist Ihre Eltern?
Mein Vater ist 59.
59?
Und meine Mutter 55.
55, super.
Sind Sie ein Zeitkind?
Ja.
Super.
Okay.
Und, Herr Söller, wie ist Ihre Arbeit?
Nein.
Keine Zigarette.
Super.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr, sehr.
Ja, ich bin sehr stolz.
Ich bin sehr stolz.
Ich bin stolz.
Welcher Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr selten.
Mit einem Drogen? Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Mit Drogen? Nein.
Ja.
Okay. Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheit vollständig geimpft?
Ja, da lege ich einen großen Wert drauf.
Da bin ich auch immer regelmäßig beim Arzt.
Ich habe alle notwendige Genzenden, die ich habe.
Super. Es ist sehr gut.
Und wann ist Ihre letzte Seite, haben Sie in den sechs Monaten gereist?
Bereicht, meinst du ja.
Das ist nicht in den letzten sechs Monaten, aber im letzten Sommer waren wir für, ich glaube, vier Wochen in Asien.
Asien.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wo waren Sie?
Wir hatten eine Rundreise. Wir waren in Thailand.
In Singapur sind dann noch ein paar Wochen in Indien gewesen.
Und in Nepal.
Da muss ich...
Ja, das war so fast sechs Wochen.
Ich muss sagen, da hatten wir auch in Indonesien, hatte ich auch mal Durchfall gehabt.
Für zehn Tage, aber das war dann wieder weg.
Okay, aber dieses Mal ist anders, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, dieses Mal ist ein bisschen anders.
Okay, super.
Herr Zöller, ich habe meine aller Fragen gestellt.
Sind Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, vielen Dank. Also es macht mir jetzt ein bisschen Sorgen, was es ist, weil es auch schon länger jetzt geht.
Ich möchte gerne herausfinden, was das ist.
Und ich hoffe, dass Sie mir da helfen können.
Ja, Herr Zöller, Ihre...
Die anderen messischen Angaben deuten am Hessen auf akutes Gastroenteritis hin.
Was ist eine Gastroenteritis?
Entschuldigung, Darmenzündung, Darngrippe, umgangssprachlich.
Aber geht das halbes Jahr, so eine Darmen-Krippe?
Ja, Sie haben eine halbe Kraft, die wir schon...
Entschuldigung, Ihre Bescheidung, ich bin für chronische Darm-Erkrankungen,
beispielsweise Morbus-Kron oder Özzettifikulite.
Das hatte ich auch mal gelesen.
Also Sie meinen, das ist eine chronische Enzelle, okay?
Und wie kann man das stellen oder genau diagnostizieren?
Als der Massname würde ich körperlich untersucht werden.
Und dann habe ich mit der Zeichen gemessen.
Dann haben Sie viel Flüssigkeit verloren.
Und es kann zu Elektrolyt-Führung, deswegen muss ich EKG, Ektrocardiogramm schreiben.
Dann muss ich das Blut abnehmen, gegebenenfalls müssen wir Koloskopi durchführen.
Was ist eine Koloskopi?
Koloskopi, Darmschwiegerung.
Oh je, muss das wirklich gemacht werden?
Ich würde beschwinden, müssen wir weitermachen.
Waren Sie das alles bei Ihnen im Krankenhaus?
Ja, unsere Krankenhausen sind sehr kompetent, machen Sie keine Sorge.
Wie lange muss ich hier bleiben?
Ich muss das mit der Arbeit ein bisschen organisieren.
Ja, es dauert eine ganze Stunde.
Dann können wir über Ihre Falloff-Spiegel.
Wie lange wird das ungefähr dauern?
Wenn die Ergebnisse gut gehen, Sie sollen nicht im Krankenhaus übernachten.
Ein paar Tage.
Dann ist das okay, wunderbar.
Dann bleibe ich lieber gleich da und dann kann ich das bei der Arbeit leeren.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ich denke nicht gut.
Bei der Prüfung sollte man etwas langsamer sprechen.
Nicht immer super sagen.
Ich habe Beschwerden, Doktor sagt super.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Blut im Stuhl haben.
Wie viel war der Blut?
Es ist immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Es war mehr und etwas weniger.
Im letzten Zeit war auch sehr helles Blut dabei.
Aber meistens eher dunkles, geronnene Blut.
Träten die Beschwerden insbesondere noch Früchte?
Es war immer sehr gut.
Danke für die Antwort.
Eine Kollegin hat gefragt, ob Sie die Schmerzen nach dem Stuhl haben.
Es wird ein bisschen besser, aber nur für kurze Zeit.
Ist Ihnen auch die Schmerzen aufgebaut?
Bisher noch nicht.
Und vielleicht Mundgeschwüre?
Was von Geschwüre?
Geschwüre im Mund.
Eine Kollegin hat gefragt, ob Sie Unverträglichkeit wie Glutenlaktose haben.
Sie haben nicht bekannt.
Sie konnten alles essen.
Wie durchfällt Träten auch Nacht auf?
Da habe ich Bauchschmerzen, aber durchfällt in der Nacht.
Wurde bei Ihnen schon einmal Darmspiegel durchgeführt?
Nein, noch nicht.
Sie haben eine Vorzweigung gemacht?
Ja, ich bin regelmäßig beim Hausarzt.
Das war vor zwei Jahren.
Da haben wir eine Bohruntersuchung gemacht.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Könnten wir als Erster zu Beginn?
Ja, ich habe keine Fragen.
Sie sind soweit.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin der neue Assistentarzt.
Guten Tag Herr Ipiks.
Ich habe schon von Ihnen gehört.
Dr. Ipiks hat mir gesagt, sehr gut.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
aufgenommen. Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, darf ich? Aber natürlich, bitte schön. Was haben
Sie denn? Oder wie haben Sie aufgenommen? Danke schön. Herr Andreas Zöller ist 32-jährige,
jährige Patient geboren am 23. März 1992 und 1,82 Meter groß und 85 Kilogramm schwer. Er
verstellte sich heute mit seit zwei Wochen bestehenden Progradienten blötigen Weihern der
Röhren. Stuhlfrequenz seien vorher ein bis zweimal täglich, aber in den letzten Tagen
vier bis fünf Mal pro Tag. Am Anfang gibt es kein Blut, aber in den letzten Tagen hat der Patient Blut bemerkt.
Außerdem berichtete der Patient, dass er seit einhalb Jahren Grafartige progradiente
pro Sprandiale überbauchschmerzenden, die Schmerzstrahlung ganz in Bauch. Der Patient ordnet die Schmerz auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10
bei 2 bis 3 von 10, dann bei 5 bis 6 von 10 ein. Der Patient gab an, dass die Schmerzen
attackartig seien, im Laufe der Zeit öfter aufgetreten, als Auslöse wurde essen, oder essen wurde, als Auslöse erwähnt.
Es gibt bestimmte Nahrungsmittel, die beschwerden Auslöse oder egal, was er gegessen hat.
Ich habe nichts bemerkt, bestimmte Essen nicht bemerkt. Was er gegessen hat, schlimmer sind die Schmerzen.
Der Patient klagt über, dass er aufgetreten und zu zauern gegessen hat.
Der Patient klagt über seit ein halb Jahren von 7 bis 8 Kilogramm Verlust.
Bei der vegetative Anemnese seien inapätenz leichter Neuseer bekannt.
Anfordererkrankungen, nichts bekannt. Manchmal nehmen der Patient 500 Milligramm Paracetamol gegen Bauchschmerzen.
Bei der Operation Geschichte ist nichts bekannt. Bei der Patient-Pollin-Allergie ist eine Pollin-Allergie bekannt.
Bei der Patient-Pollin-Allergie ist eine Pollin-Allergie bekannt.
Die Allergie ist durch Rhinoconjunktivitis, aber dauert 1 bis 2 Wochen lang.
Der Patient ist Projektmanager und ist zufrieden mit der Arbeit.
Der Patient ist verheiratet und lebt mit seiner Frau. Er hat noch keine Kinder.
Bei der Anemnese sei nichts auffällig.
Der Patient ist nicht traurig und hat keinen Kontakt mit dem Droger.
Er hat mitgeteilt, er ist sehr stressig und treibt Sport.
Die Annamnistischen Angaben durch den Am-Ehe-Stand auf Morbus-Kron hin.
Der Patient ist auf Morbus-Kron hin.
Er hat mitgeteilt, er ist sehr stressig und treibt Sport.
Wenn sich der Patient auf Morbus-Kron bestätigt, würde ich den Patienten aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich auf die Anlage des Elektrolytes einleiten.
Dann würde ich den Patienten auf die Anlage des Elektrolytes einleiten.
Gegen Morbus-Kron würde ich den Metatox-Satz einleiten.
Wenn die Diagnose da ist, kommt als Zweites die Therapie.
Wenn die Therapie auf Morbus-Kron geht, dann kommt als Zweites die Therapie.
Dann kommt als Zweites die Therapie.
Wenn die Diagnose da ist, kommt als Zweites die Therapie.
Der Patient hat 41 Jahre und vorher keine Beschwerden.
Bei den Prüfungen sollte man den Unterschied der Symptome von Morbus-Kron und Koalithys-Ulserosa kennen.
Die anderen Kollegen haben Gastroenterologen.
Es kann auch Morbus-Vipel sein.
Es kann auch Grönchen, Reiseanamnese und Gewichtsverlust sein.
Es kann Morbus-Kron im gesamten Verdankstrakt vom Mund bis zum Auftritt.
Es kann Morbus-Vipel sein.
Es kann auch Morbus-Vipel sein.